foreign
[Music]
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud proud and do not give a
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you eating
ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony them
[Music]
oh my my
grandpa really should start figuring out
how to keep your Big Macs in KFC just
saying looks like the city of New York
is setting up for the arrest of Donald
Trump rather it happens tomorrow or the
next day or the day after that it seems
as if we are getting to the final hours
of the first Trump arrest which I
believe will be the first the next the
next 18 months two years
it's gonna be a wild ride oh it's Gonna
Be Wild
out there in this country yeah it's
already starting to um
you can you can smell
the desperation that manga is in here
I mean it's it's kind of hilarious I
mean yes are we Crossing rubicons in
this country that we've never places
that we've never been we're a former
president would be uh convicted charged
convicted of of felony crimes
misdemeanors
um like hush money payments or fraud tax
fraud uh tax evasion probably probably
witness tampering
um
I would not be surprised if that's where
the Manhattan da is going with this
actually I mean how how could you take
that out of the realm of possibility
here
but maybe maybe just maybe
that's what changed Alan Bragg's mind
was the evidence of witness tampering we
know we know Donald Trump has a history
of this
with the witness tampering that went on
with the January 6 select committees
we know that we know we know he
obstructs
at every single pass today is another
attempt
of trying to delay and obstruct to have
this attorney Costello who whose
credibility is questionable at best
going to testify on Michael Cohen's
credibility
sure let me tell you
again this is all desperation you had
the house uh GOP this morning I believe
it's the Judiciary Committee of Jim
Jordan uh putting out a state yes it's a
house judicial Judiciary Committee the
GOP and Jim Jordan and James Comer
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan and
Jim q and on Comer
putting out a statement this morning
that they're going to demand all the
evidence that the Manhattan D.A has look
hey fellas sit down
take a deep breath we're all
going to get to see the evidence in
court you idiots
what what don't they understand about
what what criminal prosecution is how
how is it possible
that Republicans in this country manga
especially after after hundreds hundreds
of prosecutions for January 6 and
possibly hundreds to come that that you
did crime for this fool
what don't you understand about the
criminal process we're gonna see the
evidence that that's the whole
point that that is the
entire Point Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan
so I I I would say Alan Bragg give all
the evidence every single drip
of it
to the house Judiciary Committee and
make sure that it not only goes to the
Republican members but the Democratic
members and maybe that's how you you
know negotiate the evidence being um
divulged to the house Judiciary
Committee is you provide it to
the Democratic side
look
this all the narrative all the plot line
is slipping away from them
they have no control over it they have
no control over over what lies have been
smashed up here and what lies are going
to come to we know to be lies the
problem that they really have is not
about the prosecution of trump it's not
it's not about the indictment of trump
it's not it's not about rather he's a
criminal or appears to be a criminal or
they can't hide that he's a criminal any
longer
hell it's not even really about the cult
their real issue here the problem they
have is the thing they've been saying
all weekend like it's a great it's like
it's a great brag
that oh man this is going to be
excellent that he's going to ascend to
be the nominee of the Republican party
because of indictment it guarantees him
a win listen I've been telling you that
for months
Donald Trump being indicted only ensures
that he will win the nomination uh
Rhonda Santos this morning basically
um I'm a Nazi and I I think George Soros
is uh has bought Alan Bragg and Alan
Bragg is uh he's Jew adjacent it's
basically the Nazi Rhonda Santos is
saying this morning that anti-semitic
little
he's got Nazis in Florida I'm going to
show you videos of it today I'm
hoping to get to it more Nazis
pop up in Florida
in support of Ronda Santos and the
Republican Nazis um excuse me the
Republican Party
little slip there I guess wink
but we're this is the time we're in
folks
and they can't do anything to undo
the Mind that they have done to
their constituents
I talked to someone over the weekend
good friend of mine smart person he's
not a dummy
and and I I said your your boys getting
arrested
and he said no no no I said I didn't say
it
so I sent him I sent him the Trump post
and circled where he said he's gonna get
arrested
and and the response was I'd still vote
for him and I was like yeah I I know I
know you would
I know you would
because you're twisted around and
backwards I mean Jesus Christ one of
their arguments over the weekend
is and it's continued to be this for a
while if they can do this to Donald
Trump then they can do it to you yeah
that's the whole point if they
can arrest you
if they can arrest you for giving a hush
money payment to a porn star
a hundred and thirty thousand dollars
and then fraudulently on your on your
uh financial statements that are
legally bound
by law and probably your tax returns to
say wow there it was legal fees wink
when it when it was just uh a payment to
keep someone quiet
because that's that's what's at stake
here I believe that we're gonna find
it's not it's not the payment itself and
why he paid you could pay someone to not
divulge how big your dick is that is a
thing if a person has seen your and
and you don't want them to tell anyone
how big it is you can pay them money and
get into an agreement that they stay
confidential about that agreement for
that amount of money that's not illegal
that's not illegal it's not and that's
what they keep saying well it's not
illegal hush money payments from a porn
star and I love how they're pointing out
the morality right they're like oh my
God you you liberals thinking that a
payment to a porn star when he he
committed adultery on his wife while his
wife was pregnant with all things a porn
star I mean they're against porn they
say they're against adultery
get the out of here
and we're worried about drag shows God
come on
but they're like oh it's not a crime
yeah but what is a crime is I don't know
lying on financial statements that are
legally bound
rather it be for uh the the election
commission whether it be for the IRS
it's rather be for the state of New York
uh Revenue Service it really those are
illegal things
it's it's called for fraud
it's called fraud
because we know we know as an example as
an example
I don't know if you remember this John
Kerry ran for president back in 2004 and
as speaking of 2004 it's the 20th
anniversary of the Iraq War which
everyone is talking about and maybe
we'll get to that
there's just so much in our timeline
here
um but John Kerry ran back in 2004 his
running mate was John Edwards
rising star in the Democratic party John
Edwards was
John Edwards had a mistress John Edwards
got her pregnant
one of John Edwards donors paid his
misters who got pregnant
money
so that she didn't come public
that she got pregnant by John Edwards in
an affair an extramarital affair because
John Edwards was likely to be the next
nominee
John Kerry had lost John Edwards was
next in line that's the stupid the
Democrats do sometimes
it's just kind of how our party
primaries work
but John Edwards went to a federal court
and he won his case
he won his case
but but the problem that Donald Trump
has is not the problem that John Edwards
had the problem that Donald Trump has is
he committed fraud and the reason why is
because it's in his nature
it's his Mo it's his instinct to commit
fraud
I mean we see it in every single facet
of everything he does everything Trump
touches turns to liquid
absolute liquid
the Trump organization Tish James is
going to cut that thing down
like a fresh cut tree
his presidency was an absolute disaster
the only thing that he did was make sure
that rich people in this country pay
less taxes in the middle class get bent
over and screwed
and in the meantime all the regulations
that he that he took away so
corporations and big money donors could
make more money are Americans in
the ass still today
okay
and then when he leaves the presidency
when he loses by 8 million votes he
won't concede and he lies to his
constituency
he lies to his cult members to
come try to save him in a violent Riot
that would overturn our government and
overturn our vote
that turned into a liquid show
didn't it I mean literally there was
Liquid on the walls at the Capitol
then after then after Joe Biden sworn in
this guy can't stop climbing
he can't stop criming
he opens up Trump media with this SPAC
where he's trying to go public
apparently it's laundered eight million
dollars of Russians money into that
thing
it's such a joke that the
investors are walking away from that
it doesn't even look like
it'll go public and more than likely
it's going to spark another criminal
investigation into his dumb ass again
more liquid
then the documents case that he stole
from us when he left the White House
he should have just gave him back just
but he couldn't give the documents back
the documents where the evidence
of crime
don't you understand don't you get it
that's why he obstructed those documents
that's why he stole them in the
first place he didn't steal them because
he wanted him as souvenirs
he stole them because he didn't want the
American people to eventually know the
truth that he's a traitor
and then he obstructed in that case
I'm waiting for the day that we're gonna
hear about money Russian money being
laundered through Trump trading
card nfts
it's not going to take long because
everything Trump touches turns to liquid
all of it
Jesus Christ you had I don't know who
the uh the congresswoman is this morning
I forget her name now I'm going to show
you the the tape later
she she says Christ she
says the the way that Trump should
um not be held accountable here is just
not show up just don't show up just
don't go to New York that you
know what you do when you're criminally
charged just just ignore it it'll go
away
these P this is a person who is
hired by a constituency somewhere to
write laws
this is not the party of Law and Order
they are well beyond that I mean it has
been a long time since they were for
real Law and Order
I mean Jesus Christ they've been yelling
and screaming over the weekend about a
two-tier justice system yeah we know we
have a two-tier justice system and we
know you're scared now because your tear
is now not going to protect you anymore
the little tear that you have for rich
white
is not appearing to protect you anymore
that's what you're scared of
that's what you're talking about when
you talk to tier justice system
buffoons everyone knows there's
a two-tier justice system if you didn't
if you didn't watch the Alex or Alec
Murdoch trial and didn't understand that
there's a two-tier justice system and
every once in a while that tear that
that the rich white Republicans live in
gets torn down and they get held
accountable well then you weren't
paying attention
all the while they make the stupid
argument this is the dumbest
they were making this argument in a
goddamn Twitter space I was in over the
weekend Tom Fenton and Sebastian Gorka
those snowflake ass
we're making the argument in a goddamn
Twitter space that oh my God if this
happens if they prosecute Trump he will
Ascend he will guaranteed to be the
president of the United States and if
they do this it will destroy the country
they they're not even looking in the
mirror and and saying their arguments
out loud to their own faces before
they're making them because they're
desperate
are you me so your argument is
because Elon said this oh Elon said it
Elon tweeted it it must be true are you
kidding me you are
you are you serious Elon Musk said it so
it must be you people are a bunch of
boneheads Jesus Christ will you
grow up please pluck your head
out of your ass and grow up a bit you're
listening to Elon Musk as if he's some
sort he has a crystal ball he's the one
that said Republicans would run away
with 2022 not even close
listen to someone who knows what the
they're talking about me that's
right listen come here
tell me I've been wrong do it in the
chat tell me I've been wrong and tell me
I'm gonna be wrong Trump will be the
nominee the Republican party they can't
get out of it they can't they won't they
done made this bed it's over
he's the nominee and he will be indicted
on several charges in several different
jurisdictions as he's running for
president that's the whole point
the whole point is is that he wants to
be indicted he wants to be criminally
charged he wants that because then he
can use that to not go to jail
how you say how you say how here's how
he does it he wins a few primaries he
tells the judge hey look I'm running for
president you can't you can't take me to
trial yet it might be political the
judge will buy it trust me they're gonna
buy it and they're gonna kick he is not
going to see a trial and a courtroom for
a trial until 2025. Garen damn tiit it's
not gonna happen I don't think the perp
lock that everyone's looking for is
gonna happen either
Secret Service is in charge of his
escort and I doubt they put him in a
pair of handcuffs
it's going to look the same as it does
when he gets out of the out of the SUV
and walks into Trump Tower are out of
Trump Tower
it's going to look that way in the state
of New York that's how it works anyways
you walk in you get arraigned on your
charges and you leave
that's how it works
style works
honestly that's how it should work
you say oh my God he should be locked
away well I mean I can't disagree with
you there but the problem is is again we
don't need a two-tier justice system we
shouldn't have one we shouldn't treat
that any different than
anyone else and we shouldn't treat
anyone else then we would treat him
consider that make that in your mind no
matter what you think of this
scumbag trust me the Manhattan D.A is
going to get him here
their their desperation to call Costello
as some kind of rebuttal witness is
laughable
and it only shows how much they don't
have to work with and I'm talking about
Trump's defense team here
they don't have much to work with they
just don't
and we'll see what the Jack Smith and
Georgia bring
I think we're weeks away from that
possibly months especially now that uh
Alan Bragg
it looks like he's going to ask this
grand jury
to indict him on felonies our a felony
possibly other misdemeanors we'll see
we'll see what it is you don't know
he don't know the evidence
hell you don't even know what kind of
element evidence Michael Cohen has in
his pocket
and that's the other crazy part and the
other crazy argument that they have oh
Michael Cohen is incredible well I mean
I understand that when you have a
co-defendant in a in a in a in a crime
scheme especially felonies it's hard to
trust them but he has tapes
he has tapes
and the Manhattan D.A interviewed him
for hours before they they entrusted
Michael Cohen to go testify in front of
the grand jury for another two-day
session for hours
they wanted to make sure his case was
locked tight they wanted to make sure
they could trust him
and here we are
here we are in this moment where we
can't even we can't even have a a decent
conversation with brain dead
manga
because they are so deluded and have
drank the poison and drank the Kool-Aid
you know what is funny Jim Jones he
didn't charge for his Kool-Aid he gave
it to him for free
Trump charges them for for their
Kool-Aid
of course he does of course he does even
the Kool-Aid's the grift for Trump
but but here we are they don't they
can't even wrap their heads around that
hope Hicks and kellyanne Conway went and
testified in front of the grand jury for
hours
only corroborating what Michael Cohen
and the tapes are gonna tell
what don't you understand about this
Alan Alvin Bragg I keep calling him
Allen Alvin brag
Alvin Bragg would not have brought this
case to a grand jury
if he did not think he had one
and not only that I don't believe Bragg
would have brought this case to a grand
jury if he didn't know he had the
evidence to convince a jury even if
there was a megalodite on there that
they couldn't refute the evidence they
just can't refute the evidence in front
of them
and again it doesn't it doesn't
matter in the grand scheme in
the next two years and the reason why is
because this won't go to trial until
2025.
nor will Jack Smith's indictments nor
will Georgia indictments if they get
them or if the sdn and why indicts on
other charges which they're
investigating the SPAC the Trump media
SPAC which there's no telling what other
charges that could lead to folks we are
in the throws
of our history books telling
the truth about Trump
and we're about to see it play out in
our society and they're all going to
believe it as a hundred percent
but 40 50 years from now the history
books are going to tell the truth and
they're going to say that a bunch of
boneheads thousands thousands of
boneheads went to prison for this
Criminal
and how how we elected him as president
of the United States is unbeknown to us
that we that we as a country did not see
through him
and we didn't see that we are using they
are using our democracy to try to
destroy it
because he lost by three million votes
in 2016. yeah he won on a technicality
but he lost by three million
2018 was worse for him in the in the in
the midterms
and then you have 20 20.
where he completely lost by 8 million
votes in his own election against the
guy against a brain dead
dementia ridden Biden who is an evil
genius and who is trying to be the
puppeteer of the world and run the cabal
and
then in 2022 the Red Wave didn't come
matter of fact we pushed back and we won
those races that they were guaranteed to
win
and now we're set for 2024 and who gives
a about the indictments I know it's
going to be fun to talk about and we're
going to use them to wedge
these fascists against each other
yes we must use them to pull it that's
the other that's the other argument yeah
we got to politicize this we have to we
have to look the the most important
lesson that we have not learned it from
2016 is we have to fight for this
election because folks I don't give a
what who invites him I don't care
what jurisdiction I don't care what the
jury is I don't give a who's on the
jury we are the real jury
we are the jury here we get to
bring the charges we get to do the
conviction we get to vote on that
conviction folks
we need to charge him and convict him of
never being the president United States
ever again that is our job as us
being the jury
so so yes fine we can cheer we can dance
in the streets that he's indicted but
don't lose sight of what is most
important he will be the Republican
nominee there is no way he's not going
to be and he will run in the general
election under several indictments being
arrested several times this is not going
to be the last time this guy's gonna be
arrested
of course it's not
he will be arrested more than once this
year be prepared probably more he he may
even have gag orders that he will be
arrested on because he can't shut his
mouth he has a right to remain
silent he doesn't have the possible the
the capability
so be prepared be prepared
because the the actual jury that matters
is us
It Is Us
we must know what is at stake
and we must prepare our messaging we
must prepare our narrative and we must
go out there and make sure that the rest
of the country knows and I believe
the more he talks the more he the more
Republicans talk the more they they try
to they try to make excuses and lose the
plot line
we will win
and we will win we will win the Battle
of messaging and narrative
this is not good for him
this is not good for Republicans frankly
I I believe
this could be their death nail the last
nail in the coffin of the Republican
Party
when they nominate him on stage next
summer because they're going to
and they're gonna be cheering yay like
oh what the hell did we just do
yeah
it's inevitable
and I'm going to yell and scream about
it the entire time
and we're going to point it out we're
going to point out the fascists and
we're going to point out what they're
doing
and why we cannot let up and it's not
just Trump it's trumpism everywhere
that puts us our families our nation our
democracy and our way of life at risk
if you want to live in a land a freedom
opportunity in Liberty
we have we have to fight back on
trumpism everywhere
and every single pocket of our country
and one of the most important ways to do
that is to form a national narrative
National messaging around it
I talk about it every day and I'm not
going to stop talking about it
Democrats are horrible at it all
politics are local yeah they're not
anymore they're not local if you go to
all these local politics we're going to
have a guest today Jess pipe Jessica
Piper Jess Piper from Missouri who's
been pointing out the local politics
who have been using their National
narrative National messaging to oppress
the rights of other people Jesus they're
trying they're trying to roll back child
labor laws
and they're successful in some states
like in Arkansas
I'm telling you I'm telling you time and
time and time and time and time again
I'll keep saying it
our national narrative and our national
messaging is the thing that will save
our democracy because I only have one
microphone
but you have millions of microphones
it is up to you to know this to say it
out loud to call it where you see it
trust me their arguments are weak and
flimsy
their argument for Trump this weekend
was there's a two-tier justice system
yes there is and you're terrified you
white Republican traders that the
two-tier justice system won't protect
you anymore that's what you're scared of
we know it we can see it it's dripping
off of you
just read one of Grandpa's statements
over the weekend
so as we go forward in the months and in
the in the year to come the next 18
months to two years we have to stay
together on our messaging
and we must not lose sight of it because
their plot line is unraveling I want to
tell you thank you thank you last week
was great we had hat week last week you
guys came through wow there's a lot of
em hats that are being delivered uh
throughout the country and throughout
the world that's right throughout the
world because you are the best audience
in the world and I want to thank someone
here who has been a member of our
audience for a long time and she's been
a moderator for us for a long time Midas
Robin she is going to go over and she's
going to help moderate for the Midas
touch chat over at their Channel and
there's so many new shows that they have
over there I want to thank Robin I want
you guys to thank Robin I'm so excited
for her I'm so glad that she is now
going to be the moderator over there on
the Midas touch Channel and Robin we
want you here as an audience member and
we loved having you as a moderator thank
you so much thank you so much uh you're
so special to us here in this chat so
don't don't think you can't come here
and chat Robin you got to come here and
hang out but I want you guys to thank
Robin and also give her some celebration
in the chat uh for now moving as a
moderator from our Channel and she was I
think she was one of the first
moderators on our Channel and now she's
going to be mining for the Midas touch
network over there on minus touches
channel so uh thank Robin and also
celebrate for her uh it's a it's a it's
a great thing that she's gonna go do
over there they have so many new shows
um so everyone go check out the Midas
touch Network and check out Robin
moderating over there and give her a big
thank you everyone stick around
stick around right after this break I
have a great guest for you and we're
going to talk about this local politics
stuff and how there's a national
narrative that has pushed a fascist
National narrative that is pushing this
stuff and if you guys don't understand
this she's going to give it to you quite
simply and Jessica biper is with us
right after this break
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
oh it's indictment Eve
sang I guess
we'll see what happens
I I don't believe anything he says if he
if he's gonna post that he's gonna be
arrested on Tuesday do you believe that
do you believe anything that he posts I
mean it's hard to I mean we want to but
it's hard to I have a special guest with
us today
um we showed her video last week I don't
remember which day they all kind of get
away from me
um maybe she'll tell us what day she
posts I guess I could look it up I I
need I need to play this video
um because she is sounding the alarm and
she does such a great job because she
pays attention
um to these what I called before the
local politics
um she does so well and she's showing
you uh through her social media channel
how this isn't local right they're using
local politicians and local platforms
and local legislators to push their
National agenda and their National
narrative is what they're doing so if
you call all that local I guess
it's that local but it's not it's a
national narrative National messaging I
want to this is the first time she's
appeared on our show Jess Piper we've
tried to have her before but we just
never could connect but I appreciate you
uh coming and talking to us Jess how are
you I'm doing well how are you doing oh
I I'm I'm I'm fired up this morning as
always can you tell
me yeah I feel the same I wake up every
morning ready to start punching yeah I
mean we we should again
um I believe that National narrative and
National messaging is one of the weapons
that we use to drive uh people to the
ballot uh and use and use their right to
vote uh to save our democracy that's I
believe how we use our democracy to save
it as they're trying to use our
democracy to destroy it and that's the
front you've been working on you've been
watching them paying attention to how
they're using democracy to really tear
it apart and tear apart the fabric of
the of the liberal democracy that we
have built in this country
um to have freedoms and rights for all
people even children so tell us because
I played a video last week and I'll
replay it here too
um you were sounding the alarm and you
actually said Sound the Alarm friends on
this video about some laws that are
being passed in um Arkansas and Iowa and
all kinds of red state legislators where
Republicans have control tell us about
what what what is the the voucher system
what is it to you and what does it mean
about how they're actually trying to
roll back like child labor laws so a
voucher is uh taxpayer money given to a
private or religious school
um and these vouchers go all the way
back to the 1950s with Milton Friedman
and it was a reaction to
um the desegregation of schools you know
Brown V board so they decided to create
things that they actually called
desegregation academies and they gave
students uh tax paid funds to go to
these academies
um we had them for several years parents
in general though like their public
schools and don't want this to happen so
every time there's a big push for it
parents in general push back and say we
don't want this we like our our schools
just fund them so um in the 1970s we had
you know Jerry Falwell and the Moral
Majority and they were like okay we've
got to get the evangelicals on board to
elect Ronald Reagan against a Sunday
school teacher right against Jimmy
Carter and they did that with two things
abortion and school vouchers so it's
again they couldn't say the racist part
out loud anymore but they still use
School vouchers because the ultimate
goal is you know that desegregation and
now let's come back again and we saw a
big push with Betsy DeVos her entire
premise was to dismantle public schools
which is why they put her in charge of
of the Department of Education and now
we're seeing it in red States
um and the the biggest problem like in
Missouri where 49th in Educational
Funding 50th and teacher pay we just had
a round of some pretty bad scores you
know Statewide and our Republican super
majority who has been in charge for 20
years said say see here look these
schools suck they're failing look look
and you're like you jerks you have
defended them for 20 years they're the
reason why they suck right you did this
and by the way they don't like our
schools do really well even without the
funding they've done everything to to
try to make them fail and they're still
going well and I want to point out
because that that's a good because I
have um children in Missouri public
schools and the one reason reason why
they do so well is because the
communities the the actual local
politics of it the communities step up
with ptas ptos with big fundraisers it
is always the the ability of a school to
survive
um rural schools especially because they
continue to have to do fundraisers
because these Republicans that they
elect in these districts where they're
having to have all the because the
parents oh my God another fundraiser
well the reason why you have to continue
to have fundraisers is because you keep
electing the people who are defunding
your schools and and and again we've
talked about it before this um this
Association because a lot of rural
people do vote on Association my
grandpappy voted for Republican you know
you've ran into this you you ran for
these races but tell us tell us the um
what does this have to do with though
this voucher system how how is how are
the Republicans trying to take advantage
of the dereliction of Duty that they've
had to their oath to their constituents
on education how are they using it now
to transform labor laws which appears to
be their their their position of what
you called segregation yeah it's
absolutely insane and if you if you
didn't see it with your own eyes you
wouldn't believe it we are all under the
oppression that we always thought kids
should go to school K through 12 like
because that's I mean I'm 47 years old
that's what I've always known but
there's always been an attempt to say if
you can't pay for your kids education
they don't get an education that's the
libertarian you know Utopia and also
that children should work I mean
um and so that they think that some kids
don't need to go to school past eighth
grade but you're seeing this in Arkansas
Iowa like you said uh Wisconsin Michigan
even
um where but especially like places like
Arkansas Sarah Huckabee Sanders signed
the voucher Bill the same day she signed
a bill rolling back child labor and that
should send chills down your spouse fine
she's made it to where people folks can
hire children and not have to report
their age to the Department of Labor oh
surely uh Piper surely businesses won't
take advantage of that no never surely
surely they will surely for-profit
corporations that are really all in for
money only in greed surely they will
they will be good stewards in this in
this effort I'm sure yes we know we know
how how good uh
for the regular people so
um The Washington Post even did a story
and they said um that in this type
Market where people won't raise raids
you know wages or
um give them benefits that children are
a good alternative to raising rates and
I swear to God that they did that so we
have to set you don't have to have a
tinfoil hat on to say oh my God they're
actually doing it in Iowa they rolled
back regulations so that 14 year olds
can work in meat packing plants in
logging industry in the construction
industry so like they mean it well and
the other thing too that I think you
point out so well on your social media
is that in this effort because the
children that are going to go work in
the meat packing plants and the lumber
yards or wherever they're working isn't
isn't the rich folks that are going to
get the vouchers it's not it's not the
kids that that that have their parents
money to to go to school where they want
to go to school and then set it home and
not have to work and you know eat bon
bons you know because they always they
always call they always call the the
poor and the and the downtrodden this
country the The Lazy ones like what are
you talking about I have I have never I
have never in my life I have never in my
life met someone like that that was lazy
see you're you're saying the single mom
out there that has three children that
has three jobs that barely has time to
get her kids to school and relies on a
school bus to get them there and I think
that's another point we should go over
you're saying she's the lazy one that
she's the one that doesn't that that
that is that is the one who shouldn't
have that shouldn't have a leg up but um
to that point about the school buses
because I noticed there was a Missouri
rep
and I actually forget his name at this
moment but you go after these so is that
who it was yeah I think so
um they were talking I think you had
said something about how will these kids
get to school and he said well there's
automobiles you know like you piece of
like what in the I mean the idea
that yeah there are automobiles that
exist but that I don't know they cost
money the transportation of a cost money
it takes time to drive in a rural area I
don't know if anyone lives in a rural
area but if you've seen the distance
between school district and School
District in rural areas it's it
sometimes it's 30 minutes to an hour
um from school district to school
district so if your school district
closes Uniontown because of vouchers are
all the parents gonna hop in their cars
maybe they should just maybe you know
Piper maybe they should just um get the
PTA together and have carpools and stuff
you know I mean you know what that the
ptas in these rural areas are really
good at making sure that the schools get
the funding that they need because the
state and the Republican politicians
don't want anything to do with that what
do you think there is no amount of
wrapping paper that you can sell though
under rural schools but I'll tell you
um going back for one second Betsy DeVos
said this about rural kids she said she
envisioned them having no brick and
mortar schools that they that they
implode all of our schools and that
children like mine uh listen to eBooks
on headphones while they're you know
working in field so like driving a
combine my 10 year old listening to an
e-book which is really
bizarre and dangerous and stupid so
that's what she thinks of rural people
that we don't even deserve schools but
to your second Point Missouri has not
only passed a voucher scheme but now we
have something called open enrollment
that they're trying to pass and that's
what I was talking about with
Transportation because
schools like mine my daughter has 16
kids in the entire fifth grade
um so if people wanted to take their
kids to the nearest town that has you
know like a big sports program a big
Performing Arts Center that would be
Maryville that's 24 miles from me one
way so that's 30 minutes there 30
minutes back and so I asked Tony just
like another person did how are kids
going to get there and he gave you that
smart ass comment well I guess with the
car well listen here Tony there's a lot
of people that work at Kawasaki on the
first shift and they got to be there at
6 30 in the morning how are they going
to get there well hey they're lazy
they're lazy no good doers you know
having that job how dare they have a job
that starts so damn early okay they just
need to get off their butt and go find a
job doesn't start so damn early that way
they can spend money to go transport
their kids I mean here's the contrast
folks because I wanna I don't want to
leave this out the governor of Wisconsin
uh this this week in contrast to Sarah
Huckabee Sanders signing a voucher Bill
and signing to roll back child labor
laws signed a law to make sure that all
children all children doesn't matter who
you are in a public school if you were
if you go to a public school in the
state of Wisconsin you are going to eat
you are going to eat we are going to
give you breakfast and lunch and it's
not going to cost the parents are the
student a damn dime and and that's the
contrast Democrats Democrats understand
an issue that parents are afraid of and
a lot of parents out there are afraid
that their children aren't going to eat
and and it's not necessarily always
because of money but it's because of the
time that we're talking that that person
on the on the early shift the Kawasaki
not only do they not have time to drive
their kid 30 minutes and 30 minutes back
they don't have time to feed their kid
breakfast in the morning before they
would get on a school bus I mean these
people these are hard-working Americans
it's it's hard to imagine that they
would vote for Republicans a lot of
times they do because the association
because they're not they're not putting
these issues together but there's people
out there that are afraid that their
children aren't going to eat until
lunchtime
um and the and it's not because again
because of money it's because they just
don't have the ability to get them there
and and for the contrast to be the
Democrats want to make sure that
children have nutrition which I I've
always said this I think nutrition
should be the the actual absolute
Foundation of Education like we should
be educating them in the cafeteria about
nutrition about food
um I don't know the contrast there if we
can't if we can't get this National
message out there and push this thing
because Dei is coming Dei is coming
folks it's a new CRT it's the new wokism
Dei is coming and they're going to make
it the demon and they're going to be
talking about it in in
um uh Community meetings and school
board meetings across the country so we
have to have that contrast every single
one of your listeners who hears CRT Dei
um social emotional learning uh woke
they need to ask the question to the
person who's saying it what does that
mean and you guys probably all saw that
clip of the lady who wrote an entire
book on wokism when pushed by a black
reporter to say say what does that mean
she couldn't say what it means and this
is why because when they say woke they
mean black when they say CRT they mean
black history like that's what they mean
so they can't say it out loud so when
you hear it when your listeners hear it
ask them to Define it what does that
mean and where is it if someone accuses
me of teaching CRT please show me where
a lesson anything let me see what CRT is
and they cannot do that right and
another thing that you said that I think
is so important for missourians to
understand is that we do hear people say
all the time that we vote against our
self-interest and I want to remind
everybody that 40 percent of Missouri
House Seats last cycle went unopposed we
handed our government over to the
Republicans and said here do whatever
you want it's yours we're not even going
to oppose you so 40 That's 2.5 million
missourians had no one to vote for they
did not have a Democrat on their ticket
and that's why I'm so passionate and why
I spend my time traveling the state is
by God people we can't freaking do this
anymore if we're not competing I'll tell
you what happens if we're not competing
and making the Republicans spend money
out in their districts like the
Republicans in my district had to spend
close to 100 Grand they've never had to
spend a dime out here but they knew I
was here and it was possible that I
could win because I raised money if we
do that across the state then we force
them to spend money and when we don't
force them to spend money they head to
St Louis and they head to Kansas City
and Colombia because they've got extra
cash right they're going to start
chipping away at our blue areas so the
longer we keep going and not opposing
these Republicans the quicker our state
gets to read that there's nothing we can
do about it we're in a hole friend right
we don't have any elected Statewide
Democrat not one since
um since Nicole Galloway was gone
nothing so I mean we did get new
Democratic you know leadership we have a
new department chair uh you know a new
chair I spoke to Yvonne Reeves last
night about you know the way the the
Democratic party is going to go we got
to fund candidates and we got to make
sure there's people running because we
can't do this any longer
well and I I think you're right it
because if we if we oppose them and have
them competition not only will they have
to spend their money and and actually
work at it but they'll actually have to
get uncrazy uh candidates because they
can have the craziest of the crazy what
do they care there's no competition they
can be the craziest loon on the planet
and it doesn't matter they're going to
vote for them and they're going to win
because they're unopposed and that's
what we have to keep fighting but I
think the most important
um message that we can that we can give
people is that you are the messenger you
are the messenger I know it feels like
you're only one voice and you're only
one vote but it matters it matters if
you speak out it matters if you find
people who are like-minded even if you
don't think they're like-minded but in
that in that Democrats fail sometimes
and liberals fail all the time when they
start saying things like Universal and
you know scary words because these words
I I come from a rural area you come from
rural area these words have scary
meanings and they're they're really hard
to underpin those scary meanings and so
we we have to have a language we have to
do like like um I've said it for a long
time the bill back better bill I wish it
was the big bird bill I wish Democrats
would have said hey this is an education
Bill here's what it's going to do it's
going to make sure all kids get
nutrition all around the country when
they go to public school it's going to
make sure that they start school at
three instead of five and make sure that
parents don't have to pay for that extra
two years of daycare if Democrats would
have been successful with that messaging
there's no way in hell anyone would have
been able to kill that bill in the minds
of Americans but they they used weird
words that scare certain people and I
believe that we these people are on our
side I I know you've knocked a lot of
doors in rural Missouri and there's a
lot of people who think liberal is a bad
word but they are one they are one I
talk to a lot of folks um and we would
have great conversations and they would
agree with everything I said and I've
said this many times but uh they would
end the conversation set you know like
you seem like a nice person
um but I can't vote for you because I'm
a Christian and so we've got a
disconnect a huge disconnect with what's
going on with what they hear at church
what they hear on Fox News and then when
they see people like me that they know
oh my gosh you taught my grandson yeah
I'm a normal person
um but I have a dimmer so the word
Democrat in rural places is a huge
burden it's a massive burden
um and in fact when I told people I was
running I had so many people say Jess
just run as a Republican and I was like
I can't they like they'll know and
they're like they don't care they don't
look it up they just look at the the
letter behind the name they literally
don't care what you believe it's
Association
um I'm gonna bring in my co-host Gabe
Sanchez because I know he answered a
question for you Jess
um Gabe welcome welcome
um did you have a question for Jess here
uh no I didn't have so much a question
as like I just totally uh want to
emphasize what you were talking about
the the
you know you brought up the whole like
Define wokism right and or Define CRT or
Dei or whatever it might be all these
buzzwords that everyone on the on the
right gets super triggered by right
whether it's they don't understand it
and I think it's the boogeyman right
it's the end of of their reign or they
do understand it and they don't want
their
constituents to understand what it is
right the how it would benefit them it
would help educate them and help you
know knowledge sharing is great right
with with knowledge comes power and with
that power comes a greater democracy
but I want to you know I just want to
emphasize what you're talking about
earlier is like we should be questioning
everything they say right when they say
you know we need to lower the age of the
labor laws right to allow it's like you
know that immediately takes so I'm from
Chicago so it immediately takes me back
to like you know rolling back or not not
even having regulations and having like
bubbly Creek right we're just having
kids tossing oh like just dead you know
carcasses into the river or into the
creek
and just not even thinking about what
the consequences are and we've seen the
the rollbacks and regulations and how
they've affected Us in the last like
three or four weeks with a few different
incidents that have happened uh they're
detrimental effects and they're they're
things that are in place for a reason
right and I think that again you bring
up a good point of we should be we
should be asking him what does that mean
right Define that tell me exactly what
that means so that everyone not only me
but all of your constituents can
understand exactly what you're saying
and I guarantee that most of them will
either trip up and have that same moment
like Bethany Mandel on you know the
rising and we'll be like well it's uh
you know she wrote a whole chapter a
whole book on it yet she can't give you
a 15 second sound bite to be like this
is what it is instead she goes this is
gonna be a viral moment and I'm sure if
we question all of those people even
more there's going to be tons just the
advertisements that they will create on
their own
for us
will be amazing right and so I again I
just think that's it is such a great
strategy and it's such a simple strategy
right it's like really is taking the
child approach which is why why and
that's that's what I was gonna say it's
I'm used to doing it because I was a
teacher for so long but if you're
willing to be because it does take
vulnerability to say I don't understand
what you mean by well just like you said
like a young person would I don't
understand what you mean by that word
can you please define it they cannot and
and your audience should know they
cannot Define any of those things and if
they think they can Define it they can't
do it on the spot maybe with a little
Google help they can but if they think
they can Define it they can't find any
instances of it happening so there again
you could say oh okay so I understand
the definition now can you show me an
example of where this has happened in a
school or at a drag show or whatever
they're talking about I mean God forbid
we ask someone to cite their Source
right you're like look if you're gonna
if you're going to uh if you're gonna
wait wait wait they have sources all
right sources I mean if you're gonna do
your own research it's the whole idea
like if you're going to write an essay
and this is your thesis you better have
uh the sources to support your argument
right when someone says well show me an
example and you're like oh well I mean
it's my grandmother's cousin's uh
nephews you know it's like
uh all of these all of these moments
where you would just ask the simple
questions like oh great you have proof
of this I'm sure you have proof of this
and that some anecdote on Facebook of
someone that you know tangentially
through someone at your church and their
kid and that and so on and so forth and
you're like so it's it's just a game of
telephone you don't really know if it
happened and it probably didn't happen
and it's someone it's like someone's
saying they took Ivermectin they cured
covet right like there's no actual
there's no actual proof behind it it's
just someone saying oh well I know for
sure this is a thing and then when you
say okay can you show me proof but this
is this is the war on information right
yes and this is the war that you fight
every single day online and I want to
point this out here here is uh Jess's
Twitter at Piper the number four
Missouri so at Piper number four
Missouri and then our link trees there I
got it highlighted there
um so and and we're gonna put it in the
chat there and I'll put it in the video
description so everyone go go follow
Jess because we we have our favorite
political strategist on our show all the
time Rachel bittickoffer and she is
excellent at messaging and so is Jess so
you must go follow Jess on all the
social media platforms is there anything
else that I'm missing here Jess is there
anything give us a Shameless plug if you
can of of of where they can follow you
because I I believe in your messaging
and I believe you do such a great job at
it yeah so on Twitter Instagram and
Facebook I'm Piper from Missouri you can
find me on Tick Tock which is one of my
favorite mediums that they want to ban
and it's a just Piper Mo you can find me
there I'm also I have a podcast once a
week it's called dirt road Democrat
where I just talk you know about the
things that are important to us out here
and just I want everyone to know that
when you live in a state like Missouri
you can it starts to feel sort of
helpless right and hopeless and you are
constantly you have your head on a
swivel trying to see what these
god-awful GOP super majority folks are
going to do to an impressed or
marginalized group this week
um but it doesn't have to be hopeless
and when people say move to New York or
move to California no I will not I'm
going to stay right here I've got kids
and grandkids here and I've got a farm
here and I'm not leaving and it's just
as much my state as it is theirs over 40
percent of missourians voted for Joe
Biden over 40 percent and now they're
trying to take you know they gerrymander
they're trying to take away our
initiative petition process so that we
can't get things like legalized weed or
you know expanded medicaid they are
doing this so I want everyone to know
even if you're in a place where you're
not you don't have a Democrat on the
ballot start looking now you got a year
and a half to do this maybe someone
listening is the person that can run
right
um we cannot do this any longer so it's
going to take every single one of us but
we can take our state back look at
Michigan look at what they're doing they
they've got a trifecta now and they are
giving away lunches and health care and
and everything and we can do it again
here because we were purple ones and we
can do it again I think you're right and
I think if we if if the pro-democracy
Coalition bands together and uses
democracy to save it instead of using
democracy to destroy it then then we'll
be much better off you you have to come
back again uh the audience is going to
love you I know that for sure our
audience always always loves commentary
like this so please come back again join
us and keep us up to date on the things
that are going uh round and around
everyone check out uh Piper on the
internet uh at Piper for Missouri that's
at Piper for Missouri I think that we're
going to get the link her link tree in
the in the chat here and I'll put the
link in the description below if you're
on a re-watch piper thank you thank you
for joining us I know you had some sick
little ones today and it was hard for
you to get here possibly but I'm so glad
that you were able to make it and
hopefully next week we can have you back
and with some more updates yeah
absolutely I'd love to come back thank
you guys I appreciate it everyone stick
around we'll be right back right after
this break
what the is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam jams skull
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
come Buckle em em em
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
oh what a great conversation
holy moly you need to be having these
conversations to small our community
members out there just like Jess does
hell you can just show them her videos
if nothing else
you're uncomfortable trying to have the
conversation yourself she has a lot of
videos over on the Ticky talk as long as
they don't ban it do you think they're
gonna ban Tic Tac you actually think
they're going to do it uh it's a
possibility I don't think they're going
to you know what I think it's going to
happen here I think it's going to be a
last huh you think I could I could see
that um either Facebook or another
social media comp Giant in this country
could buy the majority of tick tock USA
because that's one thing that gets lost
in this conversation is there's Tick
Tock and then there's Tick Tock USA and
a lot of people don't understand that
they're two different apps right it's
not the same amp it's two
different apps and and what what the
government really wants is reassurance
that Tick Tock USA is not sharing our
data with the CCP yeah my only problem I
mean my biggest problem well okay for
side note I do want to make a correction
you said Wisconsin earlier though Tony
Evers uh of uh of
of Wisconsin did propose it but it was
the Minnesota Governor I'm sorry I'm
sorry yes you are right um I'm sorry yes
I did misspeak yeah yeah I did miss I
just wanted I saw people in the chat and
I I didn't want to interrupt the uh oh
no it's okay it's okay sometimes I'm a
bonehead what are you gonna do
that's totally at least I'll admit when
I'm wrong it's very rare it's very rare
that I that not that I it's very rare
that I admit it's very rare that I am
wrong but right no yeah of course of
course I was I was wrong I was wrong
right right so what I will say is that
uh
is I think I think this is a dumb this
is super dumb right which The Tick Tock
thing yeah that I'm wrong no I mean no
no no it's no no let's everyone
acknowledge where we are on the show
right
listen listen Wisconsin Minnesota I
don't mean to offend anybody but us us
down here us down here in the South part
of the Midwest don't know the difference
we really do right yeah you're like
somewhere in the North Woods area don't
up there don't you know I'm just I'm
just Aaron uh isn't that in that Canadia
you don't you know okay go ahead I'm
sorry I didn't mean to offend any one of
them no no I mean you didn't offend me
I know I am what I will say is that uh I
think the I think the tick tock ban is
dumb and and I'll and I'll explain why
now part of me goes oh great it's one
less app for me to use right because I
got a post on Twitter and I gotta it is
a pain in the ass right you got to
remember the whole thing tick tock's
algorithm doesn't work for people like
us anymore really anyway
it's just one of those things that's I'm
just like ah you know can I
remember to post this on another social
network probably not
uh I mean I'm remembering to post on
YouTube these days because I wasn't
before
so Tick Tock I think it's dumb because
if someone wanted your date if China
wanted your data China already has your
data right China already has your data
from the other apps that you download
from the like wow are you saying are you
saying that China has other apps on our
phones I'm saying they have all the apps
I'm saying there's other electronics
that you buy from Amazon and other
places that come from China right
they're you know there are there are
some products when you download the app
it's in completely in you know it's in
uh Mandarin or Cantonese it's you can't
read it right like it is an app where
you connect something to a device
and you're gonna honestly tell me that
there might not or they're they're you
know there might not be something that's
on that device when you download that
app that you know could be stealing data
I know that obviously Apple is very
secure about how they have their privacy
and whatnot but at the same time it's
like things could come through that you
wouldn't know right and so there is so
many apps and devices and other products
that we interact with on a daily basis
that comes from China that could be
stealing our data right your anything
you do on your phone
any app you use not even from China
but any marketing tools or anything like
that people are taking they're getting
your email they're getting your username
they're getting your phone number right
and then that database gets hacked oops
now it's leaked online right that's even
worse so you have all of these different
things that we do we give our
information out freely we willingly give
our information out to anyone who says
hey you gotta sign up and give us your
email right well isn't that the payment
though when you go in the App Store and
the app's like hey it's free it's a free
app that's right right so yeah they're
really what you're paying and it's not
even here's the thing and it could not
even be an app right you could go on to
some website and be like oh you gotta
put your email in right and if you don't
have I don't know like an alternative or
an alias email you put in your real
email then they're gonna send you junk
that's then you know that that uh that
that user base
database yeah it gets hacked and then oh
great your password wasn't secure it
wasn't encrypted on whatever they were
storing it your username's out there you
got pwned like all of this stuff in
terms of your information out there but
again we give this stuff willingly right
right well yeah absolutely we want our
apps to be free
yeah I know right it's a
socialism right but the reason the
reason that there is this I believe this
bipartisan uh agreement is because Tick
Tock isn't owned by one of these major
corporations right it isn't owned by a
large investor it isn't owned by a large
hedge fund that has a majority stake
right do you think if that's the case
then the federal government will be at
ease because they'll have more control
over that company and yeah I think so
because if you have to because like
that's the confidence they're looking
for right I mean I I think for as
for as much bad is obviously in Tick
Tock because it is a social media
Network
uh I also think there's good right and
that it's not really controlled by any
of these large corporations but at the
same time right like you have to
question why both parties are willing to
cease operations if that really was the
problem then we'd take this same type of
approach to other social networks right
well and I I agree with you but I also
want to push back because I think right
now in our country if we have both
parties agreeing on something uh and I I
think this is is something we should pay
attention to and I'm not saying that
they should or they shouldn't right
right
um I I actually don't know the evidence
that they're using to say they should
ban it because I don't actually think
they're telling us exactly why they see
it as a danger but what I do believe is
that the confidence that um the
proponent the the people who are for
Banning it right yeah
um the people who want it to be banned
what they're looking for is confidence
that the evidence that they see that
it's compromising and dangers to
Americans will be ceased if they have a
certain ownership of tick tock USA or
certain competence which I believe that
it's sad to say but in our capitalist
system with these politicians the one
thing that they understand is uh lobbies
and the lobbies if if they can have
control uh if the lobby has control over
Tick Tock USA not Tick Tock in China but
Tick Tock USA that it can be controlled
uh inside the government because I
believe that the ultimate thing that
we're looking for here is not to ban
this app or that app or this app is to
actual actually have some good actual
legislation that gives some direction
for social media in this country and
give some direction to the app stores
for social media apps in this country
because if we have that if we have and
Europe is doing it now they're passing a
lot of legislation that gives more
um More groundwork For What social media
is supposed to be in what it's not
supposed to be and how we keep the
dangers of misinformation out of social
media
um and and I think they're kind of
they're at the Forefront of it which
usually is backwards but they truly are
Europe is is much more advanced in in
being concerned about social media and
doing something about it where we're
just like well we'll just ban this app
we'll just bang it right right you know
what I mean yeah book Banning and app
Banning for everybody here yeah I mean
like you know Banning doesn't
without an actual policy or like game
plan you think that like if we ban it
it'll get rid of the problem right if we
ban trans people or the lgbtq or drag or
whatever it is like you don't think that
there's going to be resistance you don't
think that because you say you know we
got to get rid of it entirely that
there's going to be a blowback a huge
blowback right you're talking about
removing an app that
what is it 100 million users daily
active users or something like that or
U.S I'm trying to remember exactly yeah
it's it is a it is a lot of content that
is that is coming through the app you
know there can be good there's obviously
bad content on there
um let's let's face it oh let's face it
the majority of content is garbage yeah
I mean but I mean Netflix Hulu anything
else like that anyone could argue that
the majority of that content is working
right I mean so I mean at least I guess
the difference is there's probably a
better moderation when it comes to like
those places that would have content on
there well I guess that that goes back
to the moderation of a corpora a bigger
corporation like Facebook buying so do
you think do you think gold zucky uh
buys Tic Tac do you think that's in the
cards do you think that's an actual play
here I think it's the most likely
solution unless they come up with
something that because what they have to
do is they have to divest their stake in
this U.S company they have to show that
right that Tick Tock does doesn't own
this right even though they're separate
Tick Tock China or bite right they don't
have quote control over it right right
and so someone else has control over it
that it's someone else in the U.S it's
their brand but someone else has
contrary yeah and that that's done a lot
here that's done a lot and actually uh
believe it or not that was a big part of
the chips Act is to is is to
um get rid of some of this possibility
where right they were using certain uh
Hardware that were built in China uh in
some of our electronic devices because I
think that's what a lot of people don't
get is a lot of like that's in your
automobile the computer chips they're
not America I mean they're American made
isn't assembled in America but a lot of
those parts are not made here yeah um so
they're American designing or some
uh of course we have a lot of news and I
don't mean to cut off the Tic Tac
um
let's see what do we what do we got
going on here uh looks like
um Biden just used his veto for the
first time
overriding Republican investment bill
um so it sounds like
um someone says dark Brandon Rising uh
so that might be some news but I do want
to show you a clip and I don't mean to
jump here no no we got it we got to get
to there is a big story over the weekend
did you hear about it did you hear about
it over the weekend no I didn't hear
anything yeah it's pretty big yeah it's
going to destroy our country apparently
what that's what they're saying these
I'm telling you these Republicans out
there saying this is going to destroy
our country here's how it's going to
destroy our country
is they're saying that this that there's
a possible indictment and arrest
tomorrow of Donald Trump he said it
which you know that that that you I can
take that as much truth as you can but
anyways I will I will believe that as
far as I can toss the fat ass Trump oh
really right again how far do you think
you could shot put him
oh the same man I don't know I don't
want to even I don't want to hurt my
like shoulder road
do you think you can pick him up I don't
think so I also why would I want to
right like you know you know what you
can do the leverage you have is like at
the pants I'm not gonna touch his pants
you know the old school trick where you
step on someone's shoe and then you push
them you know what I'm saying Oh you
mean like a flat tire kind of thing no
no no on the front of their shoe because
he wears the he wears the list so you
step on the front of his shoe and then
you give him a real hard push in the
shoulders dude dude will fall down like
a like a fresh cut tree yeah I got that
or you could do the whole thing if you
got a partner they could get behind him
you know
yeah oh yeah for sure that too and that
might be the farthest way to throw him I
don't know right but let me show you
something here
they're setting up for a parade in New
York did you know this there's going to
be a parade it's a perp parade but it's
a parade look at this they're building a
wall yeah well you know
[Music]
and turn himself in now this is the
story over the weekend okay now the
story is now we we said it last Friday
because and I actually predicted it on
the thumbnail that his luck is running
out is what I actually said on the
thumbnail and that is getting closer
indictment and I knew he was going to
get indicted because of the crazy ass
lunatic statements that he was giving I
mean he's only signaling that his team
knew that Alan Alvin Bragg is saying yes
I'm going to present charges and they
are going to be felonies
um now I don't know if it's going to be
Tuesday and there's apparently been a
lot of negotiation with secret service
to act should be the ones that turn them
in and I don't think there's going to be
a perp walk like people want it's just
going to be him getting out of the SUV
Secret Service escorting him in the
building and then you're going to see
him exit the building with Secret
Service he's not gonna I'm gonna
handcuff him I don't think no no and
most the time when you self-surrender
like this they don't even handcuff you
in the courthouse right they'll detain
you they'll detain you in the courthouse
while you're waiting to be arraigned but
they don't they don't actually handcuff
yeah I mean like this is the way that I
look at it right so he said this weekend
he said on Tuesday I'm going to be
arrested the greatest president or
whatever the he lied about he
said I'm going to be arrested Tuesday
which again you got to take everything
with a grain of salt and by that I mean
like a huge nugget of salt
because
uh it's just something that you can take
you ever go to Sam's Club and see those
like 50 oh yeah
right right you just can't I mean like
you cannot believe because here's the
thing too right like especially if
Michael Cohen is going in today and
they've got some other witness which
they say is Costello right that's
supposed to be didn't that sound like a
mob name and it is because the from The
Departed this out on my patreon last
night on the Sunday rant that that Frank
Costello Jack Nicholson's character yeah
on the Departed his last name is
Costello I was like I know that sounds
familiar when I read the report there's
also Elvis Costello which is not a you
know a mob member it still sounds Mobby
yeah
um but you got to take obviously what he
says with a grain of salt I mean you you
gotta you gotta question what he's
saying and you also gotta say ask
yourself why he's saying it right and I
think that's the biggest thing too which
is
Trump says oh you got a protest protest
protest you got to protest protest
protest we got to take our nation back
because I'm being arrested on Tuesday
right the the leading candidate and
former president United States will be
arrested on Tuesday of next week
protests take our country back that type
of right
it really is I'd love to read it but
Jesus Christ Stalin and and borders with
an a it's it's crazy nonsense of
misspellings and just complete
but
you look at what he said right and he
says I'm going to be arrested on Tuesday
you got a protest okay so we know he has
the history of this right he did it on
January 6th when he was at the ellipse
and he said
uh you guys need to March I'll be with
you go to the Capitol uh we're gonna
show them exactly what we have to say
like exactly we had to show our
representative what uh let our voices be
heard right
uh
uh so we've heard that and we've seen
the outcome of rhetoric like that before
right so to play dumb and be like ah
that won't happen again and we'll see
do I think as many people show up no
it's hard to say I don't think I mean
you got like close to a thousand people
why are they Tamp is that because we
were in it we were in a space a Twitter
space yeah on Saturday and I I
triggered uh Tom Fenton the guy who
wears his shirts two sizes too small
they really Dr Sue should write a book
about him yeah um and then and then
there's Sebastian Gorka which I really
pissed him off he got really mad
he even blocked me because yeah well he
got he got pissed off when I said that
because I came on and I was like look I
don't think this is the strongest case
to like bring Trump down
but the only reason we know about
Tuesday is the same reason we only knew
about Mar-A-Lago is because this guy
bitched and moaned on truth you said
and moan I mean they went berserk
like you he has the right
to be he's a victim he's a victim okay
he has the right to and I'm like
Jesus Christ you people are such
ass Sebastian Gorka was like
yeah he was like oh you he has the right
to he has the right to and
moan all right I'm Sebastian golca and
I'm a simp Trump suckling that
cuck you know it's just Sebastian Gorka
is 100 a sip but on this space that Tony
and Iran and we both spoke on it it was
pretty funny
because there are other people who are
like oh will you have you mean like
because his voice was suppressed and he
had to make his own social network and
then in the back of my mind I wanted to
speak before a bunch of people like
chimed in and I was like yeah you mean
the one where he took eight million
dollars from this uh right Russian also
being investigated for that but I mean
that's that's what these boneheads don't
understand it's like and I tried to say
it up uh because I even I even said
because Tom Fenton tried to make the
argument he's like well uh and this is
the stupid thing I'm gonna play around
DeSantis video here in a second
um this is a stupid argument he's he
Sorrows backed and he's Democratic
elected he's an elected Democrat I'm
like yeah he's elected so elect a new
one next time man this is the one you
got our and then he tried to say the the
United States Attorney General it's not
it's not for the people I'm like what
the are you talking about eight
million more people made sure that Joe
Biden would pick the Attorney General
okay that is what we did it's called
democrac
you people always are yelling and
screaming that this isn't a democracy
it's a republic like what the it
was it was funny when you pointed out
how certain people are elected it was
like Hey it got quiet yeah it got real
quiet real quick Ben didn't say he was
speechless which is rare for that right
I mean you know so also while this is
happening uh Fred for the people who are
listening and watching like Tony and I
were texting back and forth while we're
in this space no we weren't conspiring
there was no obstruction no collusion in
the Twitter space so for the for most of
it I was just listening and then I had
like had breakfast and I was listening
to Tony talk and then later on I I came
on so it was it was interesting to see
people talking like oh this is
you know this is there's no crime
there's no evidence and there was one
guy uh who I believe he was Republican
and he's a lawyer and he's like look
look I'll be the first one to say if
this is but as a lawyer like we
can't totally dismiss this without
knowing and he hates he hates the
Manhattan dies apparently and he's like
look he's like look he thinks there's
weaponization of gov all kinds of crazy
ass I mean he doesn't even like
he's like look Tom you can't say
unequivocally unless you've seen the
evidence and you're a member of the
grand jury that you know that there's no
case here you can't say that I mean you
can say that but it makes you look
really stupid and that was one
thing that really triggered uh Gorka and
Tom Fenton when I said it I said hey you
two I hope you two keep using your First
Amendment right anywhere you possibly
can and the reason why is because you
are making uh average Americans walk
towards the liberal ideology that you're
terrified of more and more just because
you keep saying such crazy so
please please never stop saying what
you're saying Tom and Sebastian you are
absolutely making my job easier of
convincing people that Trump and
trumpism and Maga is lunatics
um speaking of lunatics here's another
statement I thought this was one of the
this is one of the best I think this is
from this morning I think Biden wants to
pretend he has nothing to do with the
man and DA's assault on Democracy when
in fact he had stuffed I don't why is it
what the does that mean stuffed
and with the quotes why does he put the
I don't know in the DA's office the
department of Injustice P it's a word
salary I think I think I know what he's
saying he's saying like he was stuffed I
don't know why he would use the word
stuff right I could see like if he
wanted to say like elected right or
voted in oh okay it's like it's rigged
yeah yeah yeah but like stuffed in is a
weird word I think there's a more direct
way and a easier way to put in quotes
again like elected if if he was saying
he was you know elected as the into the
DA's office right with the Department of
Justice people then I was like okay I
get what you're saying but he has stuff
the DA's office so like oh no I'm sorry
I'm saying stuffed meaning he brought
people in no sorry not elected but he's
saying he stuffed it now I don't know
why you would use quotes with stuff
that's not no it's weird you would just
say stuff no quotes he has stuffed the
DA's office with the Department of
injustice people there you go because he
already used Injustice as a play on
Justice it's done right he doesn't have
to put stuffed in quotes he's he he
filled it with right he whatever he
wants to use he doesn't have to use
quotes here well here's what I think
he's getting to because this was an
argument that Tom Fenton was making in
that stupid space Bragg is a
Soros racist in Reverse which oh my God
so okay I don't know if you guys know
this Al Alvin Alvin Bragg is a black man
he's a Democrat and it is possible I
don't know that there's any real
evidence of it that George Soros may
have
contributed to his campaign it's a thing
that it's a thing that you can do you
can actually contribute anyone you you
out there contribute to Democrat
campaigns Republican campaigns this idea
that George Soros gives Democratic
causes and they did this in this space
and uh Brian called him out he's like
you got you guys are really being kind
of anti-Semitic it's kind of got this uh
it smells like no what he said was
because another guy came in and was
trying to be like well let's be careful
about how early he was like let's be
careful about uh the anti-semitic uh
claims we're making
what actually Brian said was this is
something that is similar like it's on
the same path or like would lead down
the same path of anti-Semitism he didn't
call him actually he didn't say like
your remarks are anti-semitic right he's
he said you're getting there yeah we
will if we continue this way like this
is how stuff happens and then he goes
look
I'm a victim of that like I've gotten
letters with swastikas and other threats
and this and people like oh send me a
photo send me a photo picture it doesn't
care and he was like okay I'll send you
a photo right now look it doesn't matter
and it's like what do you want the proof
or not well I mean it's funny because
here is here is the
um uh the Florida fascist Rhonda Santos
taking questions this morning and
somehow he comes around to the saying
all right let's listen to a little bit
of what um what uh Hitler mini has to
say
standard we wanted to know what your
thoughts are on the rumored Trump
indictment and if you have any role in
it um if charges are brought on him will
you have any role in extradition to New
York the question that Ron DeSantis
doesn't want and he doesn't want to have
to say no I'm not going to stand in the
way is because
he he did play A Part
in the Mar-A-Lago investigation right he
already knew right but and the part was
he didn't do anything he just stood back
it's like whatever you want to do act
like I didn't hear it right right hear
no evil
what happened he knew right he actively
chose to be like well this might be a
good way for me to Cozy on in right it
wasn't it wasn't by the way I mean he's
losing more and more supporters just
because he's the governor honestly if
Rhonda Santos wants to win he needs to
resign right now as uh it's literally
the law well right right now it is he
trying to change it but if he wants to
get in this race and have any kind of
chance he would resign today and he
would get in the race tomorrow that's
what he would do but he's not going to
do that that's why he's not going to get
in that's why he's not going to win but
you know that's my proof let's listen to
what Ron DeSantis the word the woke word
salad that he well I should say the
anti-semitic woke word salad that he
uses because I'm gonna I'm gonna tell
you what he's saying here
so I've seen rumor swirl I have not seen
any facts uh yet and so I don't know
what's going to happen but I do know
this the the Manhattan district attorney
is a Soros funded prosecutor there it is
there it is there's the woke cabalism
the the the the the oh he's a he's a Jew
adjacent wink that's what he's saying
that when they say woke they mean black
when they say Soros they mean Jewish
yeah yeah that's what they that's what
the they mean and that's what Brian
was trying to say is that's what you
guys sound like when you're saying
because there's no back base that Soros
is somehow some evildoer controlling
and but you say it all the time
which makes us believe that you are
speaking in code which you are right
because let's remember Rhonda Santos has
not spoken out against any uh Nazis real
Nazis in Florida yeah he hasn't spoken
about the Nazis who are outside of
Disney World right or outside of other
conventions the the I think here too is
it's not only them being like uh because
what happens here is like someone
someone might legitimately want to be
like oh well George Soros like
miles Chong was in the space Oh yeah and
he's like oh George Soros did this and
this and whatever and it was like look
someone said can you just he's like I'm
going to try to describe and they said
can you I think it was Brian I think
Brian said can you give us a synopsis
without saying deep State yeah yeah they
it's it is amazing when you're in these
spaces how much they can't they have
delusional it is it is hilarious so
there was a moment where
um
where where Miles said that in the chat
and and Brian was like dude I don't know
the context to whatever happens so I
can't speak on it right which is the
appropriate thing to say like I don't
I don't know I can't speak on it so I'm
not gonna add my opinion or what my my
thoughts are
but Brian's saying like look you guys
are saying this stuff and what happens
is people conflate the two so they think
Soros deep State and then there's this
whole other side of it which is you know
the Great Awakening and George Soros and
the banks and this and that and it's all
this like anti-jewish rhetoric and
anti-Semitism all this stuff so when
people say this like Ron DeSantis and
others and they say oh George Soros and
Soros funded this and that it means like
Tony said it's complete anti-Semitism
that is all that it is it means if
you're not a if you're this is in there
in their minds if you're not a Jew you
are Jew adjacent right and that is not
that is not okay with them and you'll
always hear you'll always hear and so
for anyone Whoever has a debate or a
conversation with someone whenever you
hear someone say
uh uh we're the Republican party is not
is not anti-semitic we love Jewish
people we love Jewish people Donald
Trump was the was the defender of Israel
that was the state they went on that
tirade in that room so people
need to understand there are two groups
that Republicans put the Jewish
community in right there's Israel the
state of Israel and there's Jewish
people in the U.S Jewish people in the
U.S they don't care about well
but in Israel they don't like Jewish
people do you know why they love the
idea of Israel
yeah you know why because they want all
all Jewish people in the United States
to go back where they came from to
Israel that's why they're like well we
want a Jewish state so you can go over
there and be Jewish over there
as as well it's it's the Evangelical
it's that it's that idea of like you
know the end times right if we get them
all back there right we get them removed
that's the reason why you see so many
Republicans trying to Evangelical
Republicans funding this idea this idea
that Jewish people yeah we should send
them back we are pro-israel we want
everyone to go to Israel right
so again when you hear Republicans say
Donald Trump was the most pro-israel or
pro-jewish president or whatever no he
means complete no he's the mo
in most support the president has been
most support for for Jewish people in
this country to move back where they
came from quote unquote that's exactly
if you want to use the a Trope that is
familiar he doesn't like Jared Kushner
he doesn't like the fact that his
daughter converted to Judaism for him
right wow that is Grant like it's it's
just one of those things that you have
to realize that when when people say
he's pro-israel or whatever it means
he's the Evangelical pro-israel he
doesn't care about Jewish people
I will tell you I think Rhonda Santos is
definitely an anti-semite 100 he
believes that I don't think Donald
Trump believes anything really like like
yeah I could agree with this yes he just
he's just an empty bucket and
he'll put if you put something in his
bucket he'll jingle it around a bit yeah
I mean
I would totally believe I mean like do I
believe he's racist 100 do I believe
that when he says this stuff he actually
means it yes but I also believe that a
lot of those things could come up from
him being a fair weather I guess a fair
weather racist or a fair weather like I
mean it depends on what room he's in if
he's in a room with a Munch with a bunch
of black people he's gonna be a
different person than he was in a room
with all white people that's I mean do I
need to bring up two Essentials I mean
right people don't know that story
definitely go look that well then he's
like how dare you accuse me I have I
have black friends and then at the rally
though the one the one in 2016. that's
my African-American right it's like dude
you don't this whole idea of like it
sounds like you own him right wow but I
mean but I mean this is this is this is
how
um the institution of white supremacy
has thin veiled itself right I mean to
be not racist
um the same way that Jim Comer here is
trying to talk about the two-tier
justice system which again I want to
reiterate there is a two-tier justice
system in this country and it benefits
the rich white Republican Traders okay
that I don't know um there was a trial
everyone seemed to be paying attention
to it about a month ago it was uh the
name was Murdoch
um in the Carolinas do you remember that
do you remember that yeah if you go
watch any documentary or watch the try
at all you're like whoa there is a
two-tier justice system and that tier
finally collapsed for Alec Murdock and
that is what that's what Jim Comer is
terrified of but listen to his little
his nonsense on Fox News he does the
whole Q Anon thing Jim Comer is straight
up 100 full Q Anon he believes this
one I mean remember James remember that
Comer is also the same guy who I think
it was with Jake Tapper when it was
asked the question about the Mar-A-Lago
documents and after Biden's documents
got discovered in his garage
he was like do you not see the
similarity here like if you're gonna go
after Biden and say these things like
shouldn't you also be saying the same
thing against Trump and he's like nope
nope nope well again it just shows you
that he he's gonna he's gonna use the
word Chinese here because they love oh
my God they love they love the words
they love the word China but more than
they love the word woke
um but let's let's listen and listen to
the very end listen to the very end this
is it's important it's not very long
about 30 seconds do you have any
comments about Trump potentially being
indicted he does
well it's very odd uh that this would
come out just the very next day after I
revealed bank records which showed that
the Biden president
uh with respect to his family receiving
payments directly from the Chinese
Communist party so okay see there is the
Chinese Communist communist China they
like that but you know the funny thing
is he's like it's funny the timing on
this no it's not they've been how Alvin
Bragg has had this grand jury convenient
for for months we knew this was coming
after he was after the Trump
organization was found guilty of 17
fraud charges and Alvin Brad gave a
Prescott we played it almost
live here remember I mean remember we
said it he said look this is the closing
of this phase or chapter which word to
use in other words a new One's Gonna
open maybe look it's not just a one
chapter book there are other chapters
right and despite the fact that Bethany
Mandel can't Define woke in a chapter
that she wrote Alvin Bragg can Define
the crimes that Trump has committed
right and so when they finished they're
like look we've closed this chapter on
the Trump Organization for this crime of
of 17 counts of tax fraud right now
we're going to turn the page because
that's how a book Works guys if you
don't ban them you turn the page and you
go oh look
the next chapter is Stormy Daniels and
they're like we already like we're ready
to go so I think the wording of his of
his of his um
his press conference was very clear
right he's like we're done with this
we're done with this one now we're going
to turn the page over to this next one
and we're gonna start talking about this
other one right this has been in the
works for a while you don't just over
and I'd be like ah I gotta like there's
been a grand jury that has been
happening that we've known about
and so when it came to a point whether
it's the statue of limitations or
whatever in terms of why we're at this
point right now but the whole idea that
he's like oh dude this is a conspiracy
yeah but here's the thing here's the
thing here's the thing I actually don't
believe that the statute of limitations
has run on in this and the reason why is
because Trump has continued to commit
crime in this on this crime with the
check I think I think it is not out of
the realm of possibility that we are
going to see a charge of witness
tampering I no one no one has said that
but I'm telling you man I I just it
feels like it feels like that could be
the new evidence that Alvin Bragg found
that holy that the reason why we
were we were so stymied in the
investigation and and I didn't have this
is because they were tampering with
Witnesses right and so so excuse me if
I'm not gonna look back on the history
like Chris points out here the orange
troglodyte had a Chinese bank account
he's talking about Trump Chris is
talking about Trump and James Comer
totally breezes over Trump's Chinese
bank account of course all right well
he didn't want to show that
evidence but let's listen to what he
says about a two-tier justice system
this is laughable so it almost
looks like it's a an effort to detract
but at the very least it's another
example of two-tier system of justice
look we've been looking into these it's
a two-tier system tell me yeah are you
gonna tell me that Trump is not a
beneficiary of a two-term your justice
system the guy has the money or at least
can appear to have the money to prolong
delay I mean today he's trying to delay
The Fulton County investigation
this is a stupid have you did you watch
did you watch did you did you uh read
that statement yeah yeah oh my God I got
through about I don't know three or four
sentences I'm like this is a joke are
you serious even me as a
hillbilly who is not a lawyer
understands this is a joke but
here's what I said about the the comer
clip
um two-tier justice system quote unquote
of course there's a two-tier justice
system rich white Republican Traders are
now scared that their tier won't protect
them anymore that's really what they're
terrified Jim Jordan Kevin McCarthy
anyone who's speaking out against the
idea that Donald Trump would pay for his
crimes is somehow political who gives a
sh who gives a if it's political
you ran for politics you made this
payment so you could be the president of
the United States you idiot of
course it's political you were you were
trying to win a political campaign and
committed fraud to do it yeah it's kind
of political I would say but here's the
thing is that they're mad and they're
terrified that their tear that protects
Donald Trump and that's protected him
for his entire life is not going
to protect him anymore right and that's
what they're terrified of that's why
they keep saying because it's all
projection they're afraid of the
precedent that this was sent right like
the idea that oh there really are
these consequences that will come into
place especially for a former president
so the idea that they're like oh uh
well I don't know what this will uncover
and also I don't know what precedent
this will set for other people in
politics right other City members
because every one of those people I mean
like Margaret Taylor green went on a
diatribe on Saturday where she
was like he's done he's not guilty he's
innocent Trump is this
I wish she would have gotten that
Twitter space Oh my God I'd love to go
after
there are a few times whenever I see a
sitting uh member of Congress go into
these spaces right but when they do and
typically it's Republicans are trying to
I saw George Santos on one not too long
ago and I was like this idiot is
on oh God
to see them or to communicate with them
and call them out because again just
like when we had Jess on earlier we have
to question what they're saying and ask
what do you mean why you know just
simple questions
can you explain it
get a sound bite get a video because
that's what will it won't be you being
like well if you look at this article
you need to video you need the
sound bite and ask them you need you
tell me what you're saying yeah tell me
what you're saying and then show their
response to the constituency look they
can't even answer they don't even know
what it is right the mighty librarian
says it's a little late to keep politics
out of it yeah no right exactly a whole
crime was because of politics
like yeah of course it's political you
boneheads everything that trumpets I
don't think no how don't they know that
yes right that's battling well here's
talking about Congress people saying
stupid bone-headed
um this congresswoman I don't know Tenny
or something like that Claudia Tenney I
don't know where the hell she's from I
don't know who she is she's on Newsmax
and this morning listen listen to this I
actually I'm I'm gonna go with her on
this and say I hope Donald Trump takes
her advice on this this would be
fantastic I really wanted to play out
this way but listen to the advice that
she gives to Donald Trump here it's
really the worst of our system on
display here and and uh it's unfortunate
but I think this is all going to blow
over because I don't see any way that
they're actually going to get Donald
Trump to appear uh in a court for
sentencing or I mean for indictment or
or any type of charge so I think again
this is grandstanding well his attorney
said they would participate uh if things
were to progress to that point again
even Newsmax is like whoa whoa hold your
horses there Demi uh they're gonna
they're gonna he's gonna surrender you
can't not surrender for a like look if
you want to understand how the criminal
justice system will throw the
hammer down on you try just try not
self-surrendering in a situation like
this just try it I actually I think this
would be great fireworks right I think
this would be a great show this it's
honestly Donald Trump here has the
opportunity to really produce the the
most interesting reality TV show that
we've ever had ever since he came on the
scene I mean way back in the 80s this is
the opportunity for the best reality
show I mean imagine imagine on on
national news and we're covering for
days that Donald Trump will not leave
Mar-A-Lago and he's locked in his office
and he's pissing in jars like Howard
Hughes and his fingernails are
growing growing old he hasn't put on
makeup in days he hasn't put his his
costume on he doesn't even look like
Donald Trump anymore can you imagine I
mean this would be the greatest
Show on Earth Donald Donnie Donnie
please I'm begging you man I'm begging
you please please make a huge spectacle
out of this what you consider a small
charge and I think that's I think that's
the reason why I think this is bigger
than just some some excuse the
expression trumped up charge Gabe
Sanchez here's why is because they're
having Costello go in it's a last-ditch
effort they know he's they know
he's gonna have to surrender he's losing
his mind on on on true social posting
his statements they know this
is big if this wasn't big he would be
like yeah I'm gonna go in and I'm gonna
beat these yep I'm gonna
beat him they got nothing on me and I'm
gonna go to court I'm gonna go to try
I'm gonna go to a speedy trial I've got
the evidence so locked up that I'm gonna
win he's not saying that he's not saying
that oh uh hold on
what is this this is something that I've
been monitoring how are you are you are
you watching the Cheeto dust q and
honors page on fraud social yeah okay
this is from uh fraud social this is
just three minutes ago yeah this just
happened
um let's see
I pulled up here he says that Ron will
probably find out about this sometime in
the future when his unfairly and
illegally attacked by a woman or
possibly a man with false accusations
what is he is he does he mean meatball
Ron yeah yeah yeah so what he's saying
is like
also do you see this dig like he's he's
like by a woman or possibly a man he's
gay is what he's saying yeah he's
calling he's calling Ronda Santos tiny d
meatball Ron putting put in meatball
he's calling him
fingers did you see that Ben Shapiro
defended Ron DeSantis he's like who
hasn't eaten put him whoa whoa whoa send
me that why aren't we talking this
is breaking news Ben Shapiro defends
eating pudding with your fingers what
the are you serious like out of a
snack pack right because I don't
actually think Rhonda Santos would eat
um putting out a snack bag he'd be like
um are you gonna put that in a bowl for
me or what
so this is this is Ben Shapiro but
you're saying because I win after Ben
Shapiro um earlier but this is him
defending Ron DeSantis for eating
pudding with his thing is it a video oh
it is a video oh my God gold I thought
it was just a tweet no here we go here
we go let's hear it let's see let's see
if Ben Shapiro knows more about making a
pudding cup wet than his wife let's
listen
The Daily Beast now reports that
according to two sources the Florida
governor once ate not repeatedly once
ate chocolate pudding with his fingers
quote why is he so excited I I don't
know okay two sources
dude it's it's reported and and not only
is it reported most people believe it
because it's Ron desantos he's a weirdo
nobody's going live wait did he they're
like oh yeah that makes sense yeah that
makes sense right I I believe that and
it's not like some salacious thing like
yeah Ron desantos tried to you know lick
a mule's butthole or something he he ate
pudding with his fingers I mean it's so
dumb especially because
you have because you know you mentioned
earlier like if he wanted to resign
right now and then run like that would
be his best that's his best shot that's
his window right now that's it the idea
that that his chances are are dwindling
right they're going down especially
because he has his Memoir that's coming
out or or did come out but now there's
excerpts coming out from the book I
didn't go there by the way they're
saying I went I didn't go there I I
didn't know where you went I I didn't I
didn't stick my fingers in a
pudding cup and eat the pudding off my
fingers me comparing it to a salacious
thing like licking a meal's butthole
what do you want from me I gotta I gotta
have an analogy somewhere I gotta
describe I gotta make a description yeah
but okay what but what I will say is
yeah go ahead sorry
but I'm at a worse time right like he's
doing this press tour and states that
are you know ones in which you would
have primaries in uh Trump also has his
uh he's got a group of people that are
Trump numbers that are now that just
last week issued
um to have an investigation
into Ron DeSantis to be like look
there's a law in Florida that says you
cannot run simultaneously if you are a
sitting member uh in an office right as
Governor you can't run for for president
if you're already the governor you have
to resign right they're trying he's
trying to get the law changed right and
so they're they're it's I mean like you
know they could have a case against Ron
DeSantis that's totally possible but
you've got Ron DeSantis right now who's
releasing this Memoir and there's
excerpts where he's like I was you know
I I'm a Midwest Midwestern at heart did
you see these experts that came out no I
haven't read it
I feel like I was born in Iowa and this
and that like yeah I'll try to find
that out here man you carpet begging
he's trying to act like
you're something you're not well let's
let's listen to benchmere while you're
trying to find out let's let's see what
Ben Shapiro says about making a pudding
cup cup wet the chatter over just hence
his public engagement has also surfaced
past unflattering stories about his
social skills particularly his
propensity to devour food during
meetings he would sit in meetings and
eat in front of people a former DeSantis
staffer told The Daily Beast always like
a starving animal who has never eaten
before getting bleep everywhere
enshrined into Santa's Wars an episode
four years ago during a private plane
trip from Tallahassee to Washington DC
in March of 2019 the census enjoyed a
chocolate pudding dessert by eating it
with three of his fingers according to
two sources familiar with the incident
um but that that's that that's all that
matters right that's that's a huge story
okay first off this is only a huge story
to them right yeah the left's not like
oh my God I mean we're gonna mock you
make fun of you because you're a
no you better believe I'll do a video
all right absolutely I'm Ron DeSantis
and then also Ben Shapiro being like
that's such a it's not a big D he's okay
he's a grown adult he could have used
his team actually do it yeah actually uh
you could have on the plane he could
have asked for the flight attendant to
give him a spoon or some sort of
receptacle that he could uh consume the
uh chocolate pudding with uh but uh what
he decided to do was go three fingers
deep into and eat it from there and lick
them dry and it's actually uh is exactly
what I do with my children uh and my
wife uh doesn't yeah
I see yeah actually Tony get your mind
out of the gutter okay you know I can't
you know with these Republicans the way
that they uh project it's hard to it's
hard to know it's hard to know where it
is hard to who knows
let's finish up to see what he uh what
else
he has to uh try to add big words you
know you know what I notice about Ben
Shapiro a lot he doesn't know how to
create content I don't know if you guys
have been here on the show a lot I don't
read a lot of Articles to you right I'm
not like okay we're gonna sit down and
read The Daily Beast article for the
next five minutes because I
can't come up with a thought in my head
I gotta read everything they write no
I'm gonna tell you the story I'm gonna
tell you what is going on I'm gonna
tell you what I think because this show
is about what the I think whether
you like it or not so how can he do
content that's my first beat but let's
listen and maybe we'll have another beef
here now you have never eaten food with
your fingers of course because you were
brought up in the in the court of Queen
Victoria so you've never eaten food with
your fingers and if we're gonna go on
like the scale of weirdness obviously
eating putting with their fingers on a
plane in the middle of a campaign way
weirder and actually believing that a
man who cuts off his dick is a woman
did he just compare eating
eating pudding off your fingers the same
as cutting your dick off is that what
he's just said yep I thought I heard him
say that yeah you better believe it Tony
these people are weird man
I can't even I can't even believe he
went like putting fingers to Santos
genitalia
and was like okay we're talking about
eating he's like uh actually eating uh
uh chocolate pudding with your fingers
it's the same thing as cutting your dick
off he's like whoa
do not have to get any kind of surgery
if you don't want it Ben yes you have
Liberty in this country man you you I
don't know what kind of conversations
you've been having with your doctor but
you absolutely have the right not to
have your dick cut off I don't know what
the hell he's talking about they will
Jesus will find any chance they can
they'll be like oh can I relate this to
penises and vaginas and reptilia and
they're like okay great and it's like
someone's making a point here on YouTube
maybe this is what he's saying maybe you
cut your dick off and use your dick as a
spoon
I don't know maybe maybe we're just
misjudging Ben Shapiro here Gabe Sanchez
let's let's find out maybe he'll tell us
maybe he'll tell us what he's gonna do
when he cuts his dick off let's let's
listen I mean on a scale of weirdness
the president of the United States
sitting there and calling it sinful not
to trans the children
way way less weird than not sure he
didn't say the current president of the
United States actually has pudding for
brains so that is it is significantly
less important to me how people eat
pudding than the fact that the current
president of the United States actually
has pudding between his ears how in the
does anyone take his commentary
seriously
this is a guy that's going to tell you
about what is weird about eating pudding
with your three fingers when he can't
get his wife wet with his three fingers
right because we know that we know that
we know you know he told us
my wife is dry as a desert you know
but again it really goes back to this
idea like they they've lost the plot
right they they keep saying that it
seems like that's what's happening like
again like they always like to say oh
well the Biden is so sleepy and he's got
pudding for brains and all this it's
like okay but at the same time you also
think that he's this conniving
socialist that's trying to remove
capitalism and the Democratic way of
life even though it's fascism for them
but the idea that they're like oh well
he's got no brains but at the same time
they're like oh but he's a
conniving like right Mastermind it's
like okay dude so you're losing you're
losing against the pudding brains what
is that that's more about you that right
there it's just more about you than it
does about if you're if your house if
your party that controls the house can't
pass and then when it does come to
the desk he vetoes it and this guy is
owning you and you guys are
saying well he's got no brains he's
sleepy he's in a basement he's got
putting for brains that says a lot about
you all right right you suck at this I
mean it sucks to suck but God damn
here's here's the excerpt from um uh
tiny D's uh this is putting fingers book
what is the Memoir called putting on my
fingers is that what it's called yeah I
think it's called three three fingers
deep okay so Rhonda Santos three fingers
deep putting on my fingers they're
working on the title
he says this is a quote from the book
right he says yeah I I meaning meaning
that the guy who stuck his fingers at me
could all run right meatball run uh put
it put in meatball there I was
geographically raised in Tampa Bay what
what what the wait a what the
what the kind of gaslighting
is that I was this is
geographically no you were you were
either were or were not raised this
isn't like uh technically no there's no
technicality here I was basically in
Tampa Bay but my spirit and soul
I was conceived oh my God I was
conceived in the midwest but I was born
in Tampa it's like no it doesn't
no you were born where you were born
it's on your birth certificate not
geographically this idea it's almost you
know what this feels like
this feels like a lie it feels like it
feels like but it also feels like this
is Ron DeSantis uh
trying to relate exactly right so what
he's trying to do is he's trying to
relate to the lgbtq community right away
as being geographically raised I'm gonna
co-opt I'm gonna Co-op someone else's
experience and say God uh
and say that
I was geographically no there's no
quotes there's no quotes you were born
there you were born in this city and
then you weren't there you were raised
there that's like that's like ignoring
that I was raised in the Lake of the
Ozarks in the hills of Missouri
that's why I sound like I sound that's
why I talked the way I talked that's why
I can't read worth the
these these are all reasons why I'm me
because I wasn't geographically raised
in rural Missouri I is rural Missouri
man you know why they do that right well
I mean so they can carpet bag because
that's what we're gonna do but also like
that so you have you have Rhonda Santos
I was geographically raised in Tampa
right you didn't want to seem like an
elite right all right so he's like oh
well I was because what he goes on to
say is like he goes but well here read
it read it here read it here so I was
geographically raised in Tampa Bay but
culturally my upbringing reflected the
working class communities in Western
Pennsylvania nowhere close wait wait are
you saying Tampa Bay isn't close to
Pennsylvania look I'm just saying man
this is magography this is welcome to
magography 101 okay so if you if it was
born in Tampa Bay and raised in Tampa
Bay he definitely is very close to
communities in Western Pennsylvania and
Northern uh Ohio go on from weekly
Church attendance to the expectation
that one would earn his keep this made
me God-fearing hard-working and America
loving shut the so is wait wait so
is he saying that you can't be from
Tampa and be God-fearing hard-working
and America love it because that feels
like he's like look I was from here I
was technically geographically raised
here but I'm not from Tampa Bay okay
right well such a non-god-bearing
non-hard-working non-american loving
people Daniel well the the audio is from
Pennsylvania okay
the other the other the other
theory that I that I'm just thinking up
right now is he says in his Memoir right
also the Assumption right I think when
he wrote this was that Trump was not
going to be
uh not gonna be running right like he
thought he probably had a pretty good
chance that's why he wouldn't answer if
he was not or going to run during the
governor's debate last year right and so
because he can't be governor and well
currently with the law that's in Florida
he can't be Governor he wants it both
ways right he wants to still have the
position so he wouldn't answer the
question because if he knew that he'd
answer the question truthfully then
people like well why are we going to put
trust in you if you're going to leave us
after a few months right so Ron DeSantis
right here I think in his Memoir what
he's attempting attempting to accomplish
is he says yeah I was born in Florida
but I had these Midwestern ideals right
I have the ideals and and and way of
thinking as the Common Man the common
folk right
but he's also like yeah sure I was born
in this state so I got these people and
I got their vote but also in the mindset
I was born in Pennsylvania in Ohio
two pretty major States when it comes to
the election so that he can relate to
these people by saying well
geographically yeah I was born there but
like I'm in Ohio and like right I'm a
Pennsylvania net hard bro you know like
that's what he's trying to say right now
right and I don't think it really it
doesn't it does not play off well
because he has that cheesy line
at the end where he's like oh God
fearing uh America loving like dude I
don't know who wrote this book and if if
you paid a ghost writer to do this it is
sad because these lines are not at all
helping your case to be president
no well and he's not gonna be and he's
not gonna run now I will tell you that
it is likely that they may get an
exception uh where he can run for
president and remain a Florida Governor
because they did this for Iran Paul in
Kentucky if you remember the last time
he ran for president
um and 2016 Rand Paul was a sitting uh
United States Senator and he didn't want
to lose his Senate seats so they carved
out an exception for him in the state of
Kentucky to make sure he could run and
remain in his seat but you know this is
all the show man and we're gonna
add the show for the next two years
and someone posted this clip this
morning
on Twitter and they said this they said
please let Trump bring girlfriend in as
his star witness and I said just a good
reminder of how the next two years is
gonna go I don't know if you remember
the Dominion later he cleaned the
screens you remember this lady I ever
get her name uh there was uh there was
she's the one who uh here she is was
drunk yeah well or at least appeared
drunk well I mean right drunk on
something you know I don't know if it's
Q Anon or if it's vodka here
um but what what do you want from me no
I mean like she whatever okay she
whatever it was she could clearly
toxicated she could she could have that
demeanor normally I'm not saying she
doesn't because I don't know her outside
of politics of this moment because
there's been several interviews several
videos yeah and but she always appears
this way so she's either always drunk or
just this is who she is but again it
could be drunk on Q Anon or it could be
vodka maybe she's like look the only way
for me to lie is to get drunk and Rudy's
like yeah true
because in this video he reaches he he
even he is appalled by what she's saying
Rudy Giuliani is even appalled by her
lies watch this this is great this is a
great representation of what is now what
I mean by next two years is this is
gonna be in your this is gonna what it's
gonna feel like and sound like in your
comments when you're talking to your
mega relatives when you see these people
on TV when Walter and the good
liars go out and talk these people at
these Nazi rallies this is this
this is what you're gonna hear and it's
been this way for a long time but it's
gonna get even worse but this is the
next two years of running listen to this
the pullback the poll book yeah is
completely off okay completely off yeah
I'd say that poll book is off by over a
hundred thousand yeah show him that poll
book why don't you look at the
registered voters on there
how many registered voters are on there
did you do you even know the answer to
that no I guess I'm trying to get to the
bathroom zero there's zero so this is
gonna be zero
is if that's how many wait what about
what about how what what about okay
shut the up dude you're even
embarrassing me you're lying you are
such a he's like look I don't
actually have evidence this is all based
on uh Theory right now right and so he's
like shut up dude we don't have any
evidence to support this oh well listen
listen to what she says about how she
signed a statement this is hilarious
because this is actually probably going
to be used against her in a court
somewhere eventually listen to this and
20 yeah
there's two things that could happen
here either the poll book number right
if Bounce from multiple times there's
two options option number one is that
the poll book numbers are not going to
match they don't the actual I want to
point out that this guy this Stephen
Johnson here this chrome-headed idiot
here isn't Republican okay he's a
Republican and just remember that when
when this painter goes back and forth
not by thousands and thousand votes
that's how we see right now you take a
look again take a look again option
number two is that they essentially were
I just did it's on the paper here dead
people too oh yeah
that's why my question is why we're not
seeing the poll book off by 30 000 votes
that's nothing what did you guys do take
it and uh
oh
I'm just saying the numbers
I know what I saw yeah I signed
something saying that if I'm wrong I can
go to prison
so she's like if I say something wrong
oh my God put it out there too like
nobody even asked her about you guys I
thought I saw him something I signed
something and I go to jail if I got a
car right
just as a reminder uh the facts are this
lady clean the screens for Dominion that
was her actual job that she had with
Dominion was cleaning she sprayed the
well I mean I mean you're it's the touch
screen yeah yeah and it will remember
during Cove it's during covet they
wanted to make sure there was well I
mean we should keep these things clean
anyways right but you know what Tony
I know what I saw
100 100
dude 100 she's not just drunk on Q Anon
she is also drunk on body maybe maybe
she drank the cleaner and that's what
she's drunk on oh she's like you know I
still own a song I saw him
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my God I'm so sad we're running out
of time
um everyone I wanna I wanna point out
that uh I want to thank you guys for
showing up yesterday at the um the
Sunday rant on patreon uh I'm I'm work
headed to my 250 goal
um member goal on patreon we're at 171
Gabe I know you've got a goal going on
and um you're gonna have your q a you
had to postpone a reschedule yeah
yeah so uh I've got a upcoming I'll
probably do it maybe in a couple days I
think uh something came up yesterday you
know life all right
he was wasted I was actually I actually
had been drinking awesome
I actually had been drinking on my
Sunday Ranch so oh well if you guys want
to see me uh drinking you might catch it
on the Sunday rant I had a few I had a
few beers 12 seltzers before not vodka
not vodka you went on but I did so uh so
yeah um I'll be having one probably on
Wednesday I'm doing them on Sundays at
noon 12 p.m Pacific time but I'll
probably do one on Wednesday uh the
topic will be uh uh Michael J Knowles
and the hypocrisy of this this Ben
Shapiro's yeah
uh drag dressing
trans-hating hypocrisy yeah so go join
Gabe over at patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez why you're on patreon check mine
out go to the Tony Michaels uh we're
doing a lot of I'm doing a lot a lot of
drunk content over there on my patreon
page no we're gonna have it we're gonna
have a party on patreon here soon for
all the patreon members I'm gonna open
it up to everybody over there so if you
want to get in on that it's going to
probably be the first week of April and
I probably will be drinking uh during
the party because what else do you do
drink you gotta drink at a party
so and some people have requested that I
sing karaoke in the party so I don't
know so go go check out someone gets a
recording of that like hey hey
sounds like someone's gonna make some um
some revenge porn on me uh anyways um
let's see yeah so go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels check out my page go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez check out
Gabe's page there if you're on the Tony
Michaels podcast YouTube channel right
now hit that subscribe button it's free
and then cost you a single
dime to subscribe to the podcast here on
YouTube also follow us on Twitter while
I still exists at Tony Michaels pod
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify Google it's free 99 over there
too then cost you a single nickel to
download that sumbitch on every if you
wanted to download it on every single
platform you could do that it doesn't
cost anything it also does not cost
anything to follow us on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels and go follow the up wires
Channel we've been broadcasting from
there as well the upwire.com or just
search the up wire on YouTube and follow
us on Twitch
go watch out and there's more and more
people over on Twitch and there's tons
of viewers on Twitch and we've got I
don't know how many there's been several
people dozens of people there's been
tens of P tons of people are saying
people
um are saying that you should go over to
Twitch and what you should do is you
should link your Amazon Prime account to
Twitch and you can give us your one free
subscription on Twitch that you get from
your Amazon Prime account and you can
give it to us that is a free way to give
us some of Jeff bezos's money
they give us his money for free it
doesn't cost you a thing you just got to
link your your Prime account to your
Twitch account so go go check out how to
do that online go check that out
and boy it's um we're over today again
and we didn't get to hardly anything
Jesus Christ what a great interview with
uh just Piper whatever that was great we
should try to have her on uh more often
maybe have her on every week or two or
something like that I like to have um
you know her Rachel bittick offer on we
should get some more people you know
regular now tomorrow is is Taco Tuesday
yep Texas Paul Tuesday and it just may
be
it just may be indictment Tuesday
probably not but you know I don't know I
think I think I think um the word is is
that Bragg is going to be presenting
these charges and I don't think it's
going to take the grand jury long to go
yep we vote Yes on these charges and
also in Georgia there's they just uh
brought in potential racketeering
uh uh charges yeah so um and he's he's
um he's good and here
um no matter which way you turn it uh
you know you on its back if it's not
this one it's gonna be an style meal
style whatever whatever style you want
yeah he's completely here it's
not gonna go his way
um that's why he's losing his mind and
that's why Republicans seem desperate is
because they are they're completely
different desperate so don't miss it
tomorrow because tomorrow's gonna be a
banger it is gonna be
and a fire is going to be everywhere the
news is going to be crazy and I'm going
to be hot and yelling and screaming so
join us tomorrow same time same place
Surf's Up you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
them
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon